Richie there I am sir how are you good
buddy I want to go right up to the
Patriots a few years ago when they were
16 and 0 and the expectations that they
would win everything and they lose to a
team that was like a mid-level regular
season team if I were told you before
that playoffs that the Patriots would
not win the Super Bowl if you could
think back that far to what you thought
then what would you have said well I
would have you know obviously things
like that happen you guys know that I
would have been surprised if you told me
it was against the Giants you know we
were we were with the NFL network there
at the the old giant stadium for the
last game of the year where the Patriots
improved to 16 and 0 put that game I was
like though it was like the State of the
Union it was on 15 different ways that
you could see it because the NFL network
we're still in a carriage dispute with
with half the free world it seemed and I
always have been surprising at the time
to say that this was a preview of the
Super Bowl and that the Giants would be
able to get it together in time to
actually beat new england but you know
that's the way they did that's the way
it goes I'm really stunned that the
Warriors are in this position right now
I'm beyond stunned that they have fallen
completely apart but you know it takes
away too when you say that because they
are a 73 win team and I think this just
adds fuel to the Thunder fire that you
know there's no slouch in in Durant
Russell Westbrook is putting together
one of the greatest point guard
performances we've seen in postseason
history and instead we're wondering if
Steph Curry's a hundred percent you know
and Billy Donovan has poised to become
one of the you know poised to achieve
something that most coaches can't even
dream of doing which is winning a title
at two different levels in the 21st
century so they're for real and you know
I set it on on my show a couple weeks
ago this is what out here in Los Angeles
Lee Clippers fans are
hoping for the one-year their guys catch
fire lightning in a bottle with a coach
who knows how to push the buttons and
they can shock the world with their big
three and instead it's the Thunder this
year you know I don't think I'm
surprised that the Thunder have have
pulled it together but to be up 3-1
that's definitely a shocker rich you
living in Los Angeles the Warriors are
nowhere near physically where you are
has there and they stolen some of the
basketball fan base of Los Angeles or
just barely no gosh no this is a Lakers
town you know uh there's a lot of
Clippers fans that are out here
obviously and and and the clipper fans
are are are getting louder every year
but they are always looking for the
trapdoor opening just like Cavs fans are
right now Browns fans Red Sox fans used
to Cubs fans might be looking over their
shoulder a little bit but they've really
haven't given much of an indication that
that that they're going to slip up right
now but we haven't reached memorial day
at either no no this is one hundred
percent an LA basketball town we're
still Laker fans seemed outnumber
clipper France despite the obvious
change in fortune for both franchises
rich no surprise la got a super bowl in
2021 I said something earlier on the
show and I don't know for sure but it
feels like la is becoming sort of
partially the headquarters of the NFL I
know you're out there with the NFL
network has the league shifted westward
is this everything going to be happening
out there well obviously the when that
stadium gets built it will be apparent
from what I'm told this is going to be
the 21st century palace for the world to
envy this is what I'm hearing I'm
hearing that there might be like a West
Coast wing of the pro football hall of
fame installed here to really so yeah
they want folks to get out you know
everybody involved at the NFL wants
folks to get out of the plane at LAX and
take the 10-minute trip to go see this
place that they will be flying over by
the way I mean imagine what the naming
rights deal this place is going to be
when you can say to whomever has the
pocket change to pull this off that
there are two runways when you land at
LAX and you will
either see the new stadium out the right
side of your play on the left side of
the plane depending on which runway that
your plane is landing on every time
every day every plane Wow did it work
for the Olympics too is this also
telling everybody fig look mad at the
Super Bowl is going to come here as we
know after the twenty20 season in
calendar year twenty twenty-one then
when the Olympics come here in 2024 I
mean what better way to kick off the the
city then to have the super bowl after
the 20-23 season two and maybe amp Los
Angeles get the super bowl once every
three years maybe once every two years
in a facility like this and the second
media market in the country and what why
not you know in other cities will
probably answer well there's reasons
because we can host it too and I'm sure
but I don't think it's any conscientious
move to we want that the NFL wants to go
west but there's going to be this
beautiful new facility in Los Angeles
starting in the 2019 season and I think
the NFL wants to avail themselves of it
as I'm sure the n-c-double-a will want
to avail themselves of it boxing MMA you
know I'm sure this is going to be a
facility that's not going to just lie
dormant on the other what I'm going to
do the math up 42 weeks of the year that
there's not a regulation football game
played in it Rich Eisen the NFL Network
mr. NFL network and of the Rich Eisen
show an audience on DirecTV now you had
Dan out there the past couple days have
we're still not sure I know Dan brought
his clubs out there any any reports on
the west coast you have a great news
team on your staff and his location well
you would know better right us any much
he was pretty much on the thing he was
on the sports jeopardy said I'm more
concerned is the flowchart work there
right now and I've down there ooh that's
a big question what now what specific do
you want to ask about everything I want
to know like so are you ping ponging
back and forth like I've got the next
question I've got the next question it's
assumed that Seaton doesn't care to ask
a question Fritz is just on the phone is
trying to work the next guest to keep
the the a-list feeling that the flow the
show normally has
blowing I'm wondering how does this work
well we look up to you rich man a lot of
hours on TV now when you're on TV and
you ping going around into a question do
you do the light finger like me next
move or do you just do the head not like
I got this next what's the move when
you're on TV I go ahead nod I go ahead
well well you as you know I don't
usually share the microphone know when
when they pin it on me it's for a reason
Paul and so normally though there are
times say during the draft when Mayock
gets some questions I get some questions
sometimes a producer will get in our
here and say Mayock next or we'll look
at each other and give each other the
head nod sort of in the same way that
you would nod your head at a co-worker
that you've already said hello to three
times in the hallway during the workday
building 5 in sp enya you'd be pleased
the catwalk between those buildings um
you know I once asked this is Larry
David during a during one of my
interviews of him during my old podcast
days at the network that when you say
hello to a co-worker during the day are
you required if you see them again to
say hello to them again and his response
was a head nod is appropriate for the
second time but the third and fourth
time absolutely not so you just walk in
don't even Alex on isn't that what the I
raises for you raise your eyebrows hey
like that's it that's the lips lightest
form of recognition you can possibly do
that one time when i worked at my my
hometown newspaper to start now in
advance or as the Staten Islanders call
it the advance they put the syllable on
the first word in my hometown I'll tell
this story be he was a longtime editor
of the stand now in advance who is let's
just put it this way the mr. Potter of
newspapering it was not easy to work for
it all and then one day he doesn't come
to work he's in the elderly man because
he passed away earlier that and the rest
of us in the newsroom that day all gave
ourselves the eyebrow raised good
morning to each other that the head nod
and the eyebrow raised like yes good
morning that's the way that we actually
went to work that day keeping in Reno I
have gotten the head
and the eyebrow raised down pat even in
the most sad of circumstances now this
makes sense to you totally debt from
your perspective like that's the way
that it would be with like it was today
when Dan was not in right you guys know
Dan was did these scheduled days off man
that's a bigger question big guy I have
really awful mind a bit you're in our
kitchen right now how did you react when
you got the invite were you made aware
that Dan was not going to be here of
course and I of course and will you like
yeah I by the way by the way look this
is my first appearance in back-to-back
weeks I'd said I can't recall I mean you
know I used to come on once a week on
the Dan Patrick show now this is now
this is my first back-to-back appearance
and Fritz Fritz would probably know this
when was the last time I made
back-to-back weekly appearance I got to
take out I got to take out the old
notebook and dust things off but it's
been a while well that blow the dust off
booking sheet it just shows missing you
I knew you guys you guys just went to an
old reliable with that out well you want
to big Lee Bakley wasn't up yet oh don't
die hi two more questions where we let
you go the Raiders going to Vegas it
seems like perception-wise that it's
going to happen if you live in Vegas
right now should you expect the Raiders
to move there in the next year no you
can't expect but the all site you know
if you're if you're shaking up the magic
8-ball all signs point to yes no
question I mean when you've got
influential owners like Bob Kraft and
and Jerry Jones publicly speaking about
the benefits of that city and and then
you see the dynamics here in Los Angeles
where um you know I think the Rams and
the Chargers would like the Los Angeles
to just be a one-team city if the
chargers don't go there and stay put in
San Diego they don't want two more teams
up north and I think the Rams would like
to keep things solo then that the
question is do the Raiders stay in
Oakland and if not then where do they go
and I think I think you're seeing in the
ether Vegas becoming a more viable
option which is
rising to me I thought a very warm place
would have to freeze over for that to be
possible nice seeing the point the signs
point to yes right now so rich wrap it
up how do you think we did the danettes
oh boy now so by saying wrap it up that
means you're up against yes a commercial
break now that you have no flexibility
but you're just going to be the verbal
cue we're not very good at getting to
these breaks well you need to help
verbal cue which use due to a guess
where you either feel that they're
getting antsy and you want to give them
the verbal cue that don't worry about
keeping you for much longer or fridge
says to them that you know you only got
them for 10 minutes and now you're 12
minutes interview get that as the verbal
rich we also screwed up my hair by not
centrally up against it and you've got
to do a live read shortly but we didn't
do is ask you who's on your popular Rich
Eisen showing up today we forgot to ask
that a former colleague from the
worldwide leader in sports Matthew berry
on ice will be on the show uh Tony Tony
Hawk in studio Oh gel and you're you're
defending American League Most Valuable
Player Josh Donaldson will be calling
him from from the Bronx on Bahamas very
very outspoken about bean balls lately
and I'm eager to chat with him on this
subject that's coming up she's like I
got to tell you on behalf of all of us
i'm a huge tony hawk fan probably not as
big as Seaton but we've never had him in
studio that's an alzheimer thank you
he's coming in today and I've never once
been on a skateboard my entire life that
will change today thanks a lot rich
we're coming up against a heartbreak I'm
gonna be very sorry cake but good job
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience